now we begin with new calls for
accountability over the latest bombshell
on the origins of coven 19. The Wall
Street Journal now reports that the
energy Department believes the pandemic
likely resulted from a laboratory leak
in Wuhan China That's according to
classified intelligence recently
provided to the White House and members
of Congress the energy department now
joins the FBI in saying the virus likely
spread from a mishap at a Chinese lab
but you'll remember the lab League
theory was widely dismissed by the media
as debunked conspiracy theories
mm-hmm
um so we'll proceed now guy as as uh
Jonathan Turley points out for years the
media and government Allied to treat
anyone raising a lab Theory as one of
three possibilities he writes conspiracy
theorist or racist or racist conspiracy
theorist he's absolutely right well and
remember for a while there at the
beginning it was also racist to suggest
that this came from a wet market so you
couldn't really talk about how this
virus originated at all from the
perspective of these Gatekeepers and I
just keep coming back to the term
misinformation and conspiracy theory
this is used this type of verbage is
used to disqualify viewpoints that the
media and others disagree with and over
and over again they're proven wrong I'm
not saying that there aren't things such
as destructive disinformation or
misinformation or conspiracy theories we
should combat those our job should be
telling the truth but when you tell the
American people that things are false
and it's misinformation to make those
claims and in fact censoring people
turning them into Parise for saying
these things your credibility is shot at
that point when they turn out to be
correct and I would just say if you were
saying it's completely unacceptable to
even float the lab League Theory or to
say that natural immunity matters when
it comes to coveted policy or to defend
all the way to the bid around Mass
mandates or to say for example that a
certain laptop was Russian
disinformation if you've been part of
that crew I would submit that it's time
to take a temporary or perhaps permanent
time out from lecturing the rest of us
about truth because your credibility is
shot and that's the point Harris you
covered it so thoughtfully last hour
that those who even dare to raise the
questions were censored we're stricken
we're canceled we're disqualified we're
shamed publicly we're humiliated uh
lowered in stature professionally we saw
the absolute wake of Destruction that
even daring to ask questions bruh
well daring to ask questions we were you
know they were doing babysitting they
were just tasked with babysitting us and
and while this Administration tried to
figure out where it really stood with
China and look at where we are now we
don't stand next to China we were in a
picture we're on our knees
I mean think about that for a second
they flew a spycraft across our country
and and this President waited for it to
get to the other Shore we now know how
many days before it actually reached the
first shore on the Left Coast
they had time
and now they've been shooting stuff down
they won't tell us what it is just
willy-nilly because it's in order to
protect us what are they protecting us
from can they just tell us something
this is where we are China China we're
coupled with them for our
Pharmaceuticals we can't get enough of
this drug we can't get enough of that
drug we're coupled with them on this
coveted disaster they had their people
totally locked down it was because of
our media coverage As Americans saying
look at those poor people in China you
should let them free and putting
pressure on
we were part of that part of the answer
but they don't trust us with answers
they're babysitting us and we're not
children
and when I was stickered on Twitter I'm
sure you were too I mean those of us who
were suspended or or censored or
whatever the case was we all saw this
happening to each other and we all knew
that the reason was because we wanted
answers I have something right now on my
Instagram feed with that sticker on
there there's no mention of a vaccine or
anything in there
they just don't like it they don't like
that I ask questions about anything
apparently
so boom I don't think that Elon Musk can
buy them all though but we could wait
let's dig a little deeper and show a
trip down memory lane with how the media
covered this
to a conspiracy theory going around that
the coronavirus originated and was
perhaps man-made inside a lab in China
and then there's this Theory widely
debunked this paper from two Chinese
researchers that says it is plausible
that the virus leaked accidentally from
one of two labs near the Wuhan seafood
market this question about the Wuhan lab
we know that it's been debunked that
this virus was man-made or modified or
anything like that just weeks ago Dr
Anthony fauci rejected the conspiracy
the coronavirus was man-made in a lab in
Wuhan China and yet this week Donald
Trump is still pushing the debunked
bunkum a lot of people want to write
love that phrase escape from the lab
because it sounds like something from a
Marvel movie or comic book both
scientists and the US intelligence
Community agree that this coronavirus
was not man-made that is not a
possibility but there is also no reason
to believe any of these conspiracy
theories that it was leaked from the lab
in Wuhan where that intent nationally or
otherwise
it's shameful Tammy especially in
context now of as guy pointed out so
much of that
becoming or you know being confirmed
that it was true
um and again just the fact that the
inverse wasn't proven to be true right
so in the absence of any facts as people
were daring to ask questions especially
in the landscape of Grants to the Wuhan
lab and and grants by China to American
universities and things that did obviate
the need to ask questions this was what
we got yes and I that's an excellent
point and I think one of the most
important points and where this will
land with the American people
that uniformity takes time and effort
they weren't just all coming to this
point of it's debunked and it's a
conspiracy theory you heard the same
thing over multiple platforms when now
we know they didn't even know so the
choice was not to say we don't know
don't jump to conclusions this is we're
working on this it was a completely
constructed fake front which is which
will and has been concerning the
American people we've known basic Common
Sense we do always want evidence the
evidence now is coming through but the
fact is now we realize that someone
within a major kind of combination of
occlusion as we've now seen between
government and media
created this false front to effectively
Gaslight the American people why would
you do that when ultimately a million
Americans are dead what is the the
question has to be and I hope the
Republicans get to it the question has
to be in whose interest was this yeah
what the money I know we were funding
things fauci's got some things to answer
this is beyond just because we're
curious this was a construction of
something specific and it was more I
would argue yes it was babysitting but
it was also a training it was a training
for us to just take at face value what
the government was saying and to change
our lives which we still feel to this
day kids out of control sobriety ruined
Americans not wanting to go into work
Americans still afraid the media is
still trying to do that it was a
training of the media it was a training
of us they are failing they're going to
continue to fail but this shows you
exactly how deep it was and how
nefarious it was as well and Lisa in in
typical kindly in fashion of course
Academia piled on calling it toxic white
masculinity to even dare to raise these
questions as well as anti-chinese racism
and remember you know Tammy brought up
the administration in the government uh
impact with it and of course uh then
President Biden sort of squashed any
investigation into the origins but when
he revived it even he was said to be
sugarcoating Trump's racism no one was
spared the crosshairs from the racist
broad brush of Daring to ask questions
into the origins of what killed over a
million Americans well because it was a
cover-up I mean we know that Anthony
fauci and her own government were fun
and gain of function research at the
Wuhan Institute of virology where the
outbreak took place and you know now
they're just coming to the conclusion
that it came from there I mean duh it's
been the most obvious answer all along
but it was a cover-up because of her
part particularly Dr Anthony fauci and
you can go back and look at the fact
that he colluded with Dr Francis Collins
along with Scientists to try to shut
down anyone who dare raise the most
obvious uh answer which was that it was
it came from the lab we know that he
also worked with social media to try to
shut down people questioning that as
well and I think that's the most
frustrating thing about kovid this
entire time is it's just been a denial
of common sense you know it's just been
a simple denial of Common Sense and guy
was talking about people who were
treated like social porias who raised
questions I was one of those people from
the beginning on everything I questioned
The lethality of covid from the
beginning questioned lockdowns from the
beginning questioned the origins of the
coronavirus from the beginning question
the efficacy of vaccines from the
beginning because I was actually looking
at the data and talking to people that
weren't necessarily the ones on TV there
were people like Dr John iannidis who
wrote an op-ed in March of 2020 saying
that it's not as deadly as everyone is
saying it is and that we're basically
making all these terrible data decisions
off of bad data and he was right from
the beginning there were people he's a
Stanford epidemiologist he's world
renowned for debunking bad research but
where was he in the beginning of this
people weren't interested in talking to
him so you know this entire time we've
just seen a denial of the obvious a
denial of Common Sense and in the end
the American people suffered they
suffered so much they've lost businesses
they've lost lives people were fired for
not wanting to get the vaccine I mean
it's we need accountability people need
then the excess deaths we don't even
know what those numbers are quite yet
what about the nursing home debacle oh
my God I mean there's so many things
that we could dig into I do want to say
this and and I did 11
pandemic specials on this network we had
every kind of scientist I wasn't just
asking questions and I love the way Lisa
put that we had data we had a reason to
believe that that lab was a problem when
our own Dr Siegel went to the
biocontainment place in Nebraska where
we first had it he talked about what it
would take to get this into the
bloodstream of the world from a place
that it would be hard to do anything
with with zero vacuum I mean zero it has
the ability to just suck everything in
and not spit anything out that bio
containment lab he said that's what
you're looking at you're looking at a
situation that was corrupted by accident
whatever it was he said that very early
on and we talked about that and I mean
people didn't want us to have the
conversation and look I again say look
at where we are now can I just freeze
real quick one more thing if you go back
and there is evidence that the
coronavirus came about potentially you
know fall of 2019 even earlier than that
yeah so what was the point of lockdowns
in March of 2020. I mean you look at how
transmissible this virus was you know
look at how widespread it had been at
that point you know but we didn't do the
antibody testing we didn't do the due
diligence to figure out how widespread
it had been at that point so there's no
point of lockdowns even from the
beginning so all of this a denial of you
know Common Sense Truth uh and even
Desiring to get to the bottom of it with
the exception of people like Harris and
a lot of people at this network most
disturbing to me is that we were
actually put on notice over a year prior
to the leak when American delegates that
looked into the lab raised
non-classified there you go
non-classified telecommunications to the
intelligence agency and to the
administration saying this lab is not
safe and here is why with detailed
explanations about their security
concerns given the gain of function
research given the the absolute
incendiary nature of what was in there
we were put on office we were put on
notice this Administration turned a
blind eye to it
um and at the result of millions of
deaths so much more to come we will stay
on this as it unfolds
everyone I'm Emily compagno catch me and
my co-host Harris Faulkner and Kaylee
mcineny on outnumbered every weekday at
12 pm Eastern or sets your DVR also
don't forget to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page for daily highlights